how many questions the same thing put
out content put out a great product test
things try it all use data use your
intuition test and learn test and learn
test and learn and this that's just
insane lack of patience and lack of
understanding that takes actual skills
to actually win is is frustrating at
times what is a local business need to
do to get customers you need to have a
great product you need to make people
that could potentially buy your product
know about it you can do that through
content you can do that through
advertising you can do that by going to
the Chamber of Commerce you could do
that by [ __ ] cold calling every
single business in town like [ __ ] man
there's just so many ways to do it but
one way not to do it is to watch my
videos and read Seth Godin books and
ponder and strategize and whiteboard all
day and debate with your brother and
wonder why like lack of action is one
way not to do it one thing I'm doing is
I'm constantly in motion that I'm
constantly emotional changing my
products I'm changing my game I'm
changing all the time I'm redoing my
pitch deck for vaynermedia I've got
different ideas of how to sell it
[ __ ] learn how to love losing learn
how to love losing like I do you know
I'm not scared of testing cuz I don't
fear the loss I don't fear people
laughing to me [ __ ] laugh at me
go ahead laugh at me I don't give a [ __ ]
try to laugh at me laugh at me with your
opinions let's talk results you know can
you laugh at me people are beating me
your suck your loud laugh Ilan you're
allowed to laugh sack of laughing me
your loud if you're not beating me don't
[ __ ] laugh
people are scared people are scared
people are scared of trying new things
people want to be poor students your
students you're not a [ __ ]
entrepreneur your student
there's student all you want to do is
read and consume and ponder make your
tab and talk about how you're gonna [ __ ]
you're gonna go do it - can only read so
much you to do I'm an extreme maybe I'm
different I don't learn that way I don't
read anything
that's not right but is it right to read
of all of them [ __ ] how many [ __ ]
books from these experts do you need do
[ __ ] learn put in the work
don't [ __ ] have dinner at seven
o'clock and drink two beers and have the
[ __ ] cuz Spurs Golden State game in
the back row with you two bunnies and
tell each other how you're gonna do it
while you're [ __ ] cinderdog you're
gonna do it and damn time see [ __ ]
Steph Curry hit a basket this year
just go do like my biggest goals I have
no fans that my fans learn for me and
get inspired for me and then don't
consume me I'm not I don't care how big
my subscription numbers are or how many
people follow me I don't want you here
I never want to hit a million
subscribers on YouTube I don't want you
here
I don't need it I don't I don't need
that I need to make an impact I want the
legacy of you coming up to me last night
and I meet up the four hundred people
three people shut up 40 of them whisper
to my earring changed my life that's
what I get off on not them still buying
my books or buying my courses or being a
vaynermedia client I want legacy I've
made enough money I'm good I'm great if
I don't make a single dollar again great
I don't need to buy the Jets I need to
try to buy the Jets that's a distinction
I want legacy I want you to show up to
my funeral because you watched a
Facebook livestream when I was in San
Diego and I ranted and I finally kicked
your ass into gear and you realize no
more meaning no more consuming time to
do try to put your fears in action great
you go over 70 I love when people don't
high risk you're moving you're
constantly moving like that's how you
have to do it you just can't just think
and ponder and read medium and wonder
and watch one more book and order 10
more udemy courses and go to for more
[ __ ] conferences enough listening
start doing [ __ ] don't be scared look at
the action it's going it's doing